I got in there as soon as my eyes
adjusted I thought oh my God that's
Rodney Christ sitting at the table and
there's Reggie at the bar and Frankie
Fraser's in the corner I just love the
buzz on this event yeah I knew I
couldn't get anywhere with it yeah so a
forger I must be I'm a Craftsman that
lost his lost his way that's how I feel
it well I've got a Banksy on I got
Banksy nearly finished
[Laughter]
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives a podcast from lad
Bible I'm joined in the studio today by
Max brandrett Max for anyone who is
unaware of who you are could you give
yourself a brief introduction yes I am
Max brand Britain's number one Aunt
forger reformed
going straight going slightly my way yes
great and it's fantastic to have you
here thank you well let's get straight
into it what was what was life like for
you growing up Max
um if we go back to Brighton Buckingham
Road you think five five siblings in a
basement flat in Buckingham Road which
is you know
um it consisted of front room my
half-sister was there back bedroom we
all slept in a single bed top to toe
scullery Larder outside Luna mangle you
know what manglers
and my mum bless her Yorkshire I I don't
love cupboard sea in a fact that was my
mother so friendly and there was the
corner shop I could see my mum now going
she said max go to Corner Shop and ask
Mr Peters you want Arthur stalker
margarine Tina beans and a pint of milk
till Bloody Friday and I'll tell you
another thing is that Mama had a
boyfriend called Sid and it was a bit of
a drunk and used to come in on a Friday
night and and to stop my mum pulling his
suit he used to take his suit and put it
painting two bits of cardboard and put
his bed on it so if you lifted the bed
your nose is going to Nick his suit so
when he was so drunk he had to pick up
the bed say run it down to Elm Grove and
get five children on it though so he had
to sit all weekend in his bloody
Underpants that was mum's boyfriend
Sydney okay fine yeah the poverty side
we used to remember to form a TB like a
Bronco trouble so we used to go and when
mum was really ill they used to take us
to the workhouse which is still there
today a thing called Warren farm and
that's where we would go in and out in
and out until suddenly we were whisked
away to the whole career in 12 years of
bernardo's so how how does a a young lad
growing up in a very very working-class
house in the 50s get interested in art
uh well from the age of five in this in
my little basement fact we had a
cupboard it was an earring cupboard and
I somebody put my I don't know one of my
mum said he put me electric light in
there and I was doing cartoons and
character tours and drawings and I
started playing sort of cowboys and
Indians you know I was in their drawing
and I just loved it what we're going to
talk about ultimately a big part of your
life and what you're known for is the
art forgery
so how did you get to the point where
you were moving into that like how does
somebody start to become an Art Forger
I've got to go to the circus first let's
go to the circus right so I was in
bernardo's and the last place I was
called goldings and uh there was a road
called Bentley Lane and it and I was 15
and I knew one day I'd be going down
that road and you make friends here
there was a lot of sort of togetherness
and Mr Pinhead said to me Max you're
going home tomorrow thank God I'm home
to my mum bless you so what was lovely
all the boys they all lined up on
benchery Lane
and they sang a song to me I'm not going
to sing it and got my guitar with me
anyway I'll give you the words and now
the red picture this all the boys there
standing in sort of clapping and saying
goodbye Max and they start seeing there
is a moldy Shack down Bentley Lane where
we get bread and cheese three times a
day eggs and bacon we don't see we get
sawdust in our tea and we are gradually
fading away two cheers for Max then off
you go with your haberset down to the
sensation and freedom wow so that was so
you'd gone to bernardo's because of your
mother's illness and TB and then you uh
released back into her care so how did
you then end up when she was living with
a horrible Irishman I didn't like him
okay so anyway he thought I screwed the
guest meter once which I used to do
screen of gas meters but not my mum's
but he beat me up and I decided to run
away okay and I got up to London got to
Paddington ended up in a funny Guest
House screwed all the gas meters in my
room plus all the others at breakfast so
walked out with cichlids in my pocket I
couldn't even bloody walk so and the
only job you can get and how old were
you here uh I was 15 years old wow okay
and I saw this men wanted for circus I
went that's for me chippy Norton here I
come okay so I dodged Affair going up to
cheap Norton they were at winter
quarters you know they circles said
winter course I've walked in there and
he went what you want son I said any job
sir he went no he said you're too well
you said 15 he went go and get a pet to
school and I walked away and he went
come here do you ever work with
elephants or no he said come with me and
I've walked into this tank with 12
bloody elephants right here's the names
never forget Leela Mary camera Susie
daler Donna Rani Sita my maple jelly and
Sally and to look after those and uh I
became quite popular he liked me and I
remember first time we went on tour and
if we were at bendy Hall in Birmingham
and uh he said max you're really good
worker you love the elephants he said
it's one thing you've got to do he said
you know it's the show tonight but we've
got to do it's a bit unpleasant but
you'll get used to it so so go and get a
bucket of water and a big and lots of
soap I went all right Louis so he got
back back of Lilia and he and I thought
is he really going to do that so he got
his arms soaked up and he put his hand
up the elements backside and pulled all
the crap down well because they didn't
like them crapping in the ring and I
said I've got to do see you got to do
the rest of them I said how many times
did twice a day you kidding me how much
and I and I'll tell you what I did it I
got used to it but I did notice that um
Lily and Kamala they used to have their
legs open before you got there they were
loving it I don't know the only thing is
when they've got the legs together don't
let them cross their legs because they
either suck you in or blow you out
okay so you're looking after all these
elephants so obviously left a big
impression on you because you remember
all their names
um what does how how do you look after
an elephant is it just like you know
riding them off you know washing them
yeah no you wash them down you write
them out right you know yes up their
backside you know but I'll tell you what
um lady America Ronnie Rani I felt
guilty with Monica I used to come she
could hear the bucket rattling I know
she had her legs open and she used to
look around at me like you dirty old
pervert
I said I've got to do it it's part of
the job said I loved him right so were
you the only person that was looking at
no there was Louis I was assistant groom
you know but I differences I they the
elephants are lovable that there were
two different things with the with the
with the chipperfields they were they
were they were nasty I don't care I mean
one of them got done for beating out
with elephant and iron bar but when you
took the elephants for training you had
to go to the the main ring in the
morning and then stand back a hundred
yards because we knew how they were
treating them we knew the whip in going
you see we both had a walking stick we I
had a walking stick like that but theirs
was different they had a spike on the
end of this on here we didn't they had
in both ends so to give an elephant's
here you scrub the ear and just pull it
now if you pull them down they will go
down and if you dig their toenails in
there and Spike them there they will go
back so if you do that enough times and
whip your lap do the whip then go right
there that's how they get all the
elephants to go whoop and this I hated
them for it but I loved them and they've
all gone now I think you know they're
all gone now yeah my days on the circus
were fantastic and not not only that oh
sorry no no go ahead go ahead I was
Dicky chip before saw me painting one
day in my spare time and he went Max he
said you think you can do the Menagerie
board something and I could so I did the
sign writing so I became part of the
chip if it was my own Caravan but I did
it for three years and and then I had
enough so I said Dicky I'm leaving and
uh so and that's when I hit London and
yes when we get into the the forgery
game okay
so you started with the elephants three
years at the circus and then you left to
what age you now when you leave that and
move time I was 17 18 17 18. okay so
came to London yeah ended up being
Shepherd's Bush okay with all the old
doses you know sleeping rough oh really
yeah the guy said to me it took me
because I'm young he said yeah do you
know Max you can get a nice work in the
bakery called Cadbury Hall you can check
that out so he went there and there was
about eight or nine guys waiting for a
job for casual work and he went can you
give the lady job he's got no money so
he pushed me through and I was on the
donut machine that is injecting Jammers
and bloody donuts and I'll turn you on
there
seriously you put you put the donut and
you bang the leave and you go it's like
I've been whatever you know anyway I did
that one on the winkly machine anyway so
I went back to the dosses and I thought
you know what I could go tomorrow night
get a brown coat on because nobody had
ever challenge you put a prank and start
nicking bread for the leads down here I
did it for two weeks the brown Co what
do you mean well Brown you know as I'm a
worker oh right I see right yeah and I
remember I did it for three weeks got in
all malt loafs and cheese and what I
remember this spoke kind of went all
right Max what you doing here I said oh
you might go on get out so I haven't got
any food for the leads so on my way I
saw a bloody great big wedding cake so I
Nick the top of the wedding cake where
was that well because it was in the van
in the loading Bay okay I still had the
bride and groom on it okay so I nicked
that and I took it back to the voice of
it what'd you get I said bloody wedding
okay I said who wants the bright who
wants the crew so that was but they
looked after you you know and then okay
then uh then you want to get into the 4G
business yeah I mean that's a really
fascinating area because I think you
know Art's something that you think you
have to go through
training and schooling to get good at
some people are natural you know I mean
but I I just just natural I could what I
think my what I'm good at now is
actually reproduce the colors but okay
this is how it started so I left this I
left them in Sheffield right and I
headed down to um I was with you know
dosing and I've got myself a few Bob and
I got myself a place in cricklewood and
I thought hello got guitar I know two
songs off I go Portman Road Sadie long
and dusty road and listening to late for
the learning and his bloke said oh you
mate your thing is crap
I said well I understood where'd you get
the smudges from and that was the
beginnings I thought I'm starting to
fake old pictures and uh you know
Portobello Road Saturday and uh that's
the and then I met a guy which is in the
book called um Sammy Cohen and he
watched me one day and he said though
where'd you get the smudges from son I
mean oh I just buy them and went no
they're too good where'd you get them I
told him said you know you could make a
bloody Fortune doing this so he teamed
up he was about 45 I was 18 years old
and he's so which and my place in
cricket would we started to buy old
canvases and fake old shipping scenes
older but you see what I'm trying to say
is when you say Max a great Art Forger I
didn't walk around with Rembrandts and
vermeers because what you're going to
walk along and go hello John got smudgy
I think it's a Vermeer they're not going
to go for that aren't they so we did
lesser known paintings and it was we
used to act we were too ignorant antique
dealers knew nothing about painting so
the painting so I've done it I'll do the
Aging right say we did a lovely old
shipping scene by Albert Derby and
proper old canvas you know and age it up
good quality old frame old Nails have
been in the garden you know dust it down
even though the cracking on it as well
and then you've got your painting there
after the auction so I can give you lots
Road and then we go there and say now
son you're going to be my dad all right
so say it to me yes Dad yes Dad just say
it again don't say my name right so we
go in there to the auctioneer Joe
morning sir always call him sir remember
they've got the knowledge and make sure
that they know that and they'll go Club
smudged in the car so would you have a
look he goes yeah spring them in so then
these picture would go and you'd do a
lot of Pop boiler rubbish you know a lot
of crappy pictures but you would show a
good winter scene or a good shipping
scene and you leave it just so he could
see it and you go what's that over there
then oh well what's the smudge dad with
the with the boats on you sir you talk
like that to them anyway
you go and that's quite nice they said
who is it he said well it's by Albert
Derby was he any good sir he said oh yes
he was quite he was noisy school was he
painted in Norris oh God we stunned him
another good keeper and then we used to
put it into auction and ring it that's
what he's to do and so the auctioneer
would believe it was the original
because we went in there as not knowing
what we were doing acting ignorant and
we yeah we used to rehearse it you know
you know it was it was it was good fun
though I do miss it and would you what
kind of money could you get from a
painting like that uh I could get three
to four thousand wow there is a there
now people say any expert would say I
don't believe that story because if you
use oils it takes ages to dry but
there's a secret if you use brolic
undercoat or not bro like any house
undercoat just mix it with your oils put
the bloody hair dryer over it and it'll
be dry in about a day age it up fake it
look there's a thing called bead glue do
you know it's the seed
Scotch glue it looks like little lentils
right you can buy in the hardware shop
in those days for about um for about
about 50 pence or a pound get a big bag
of it so take that back to the studio
put it in a dish right in a pan
cold water leave it overnight next
morning goes to a jelly on the stove
right think right here comes to a
varnish take your painting brush it all
over take it to an electric fire I wish
I've still got circulate it and you can
hear it cracking I think bloody hell
that's enough cracks keep going like
that don't get it soon there because
it'll blister and then think right got
enough and Sami say yep little bit in
the sky DMX tonight okay so let me then
on the floor with it wash the bead go
off because it's a water base empty a
Hoover on it because all the cracks now
you know rub it all in I think good old
varnish old Nails in the frame down to
the auction rooms hello John got smudge
here so and that's how you'd age it yeah
wow and so you tip you'd literally paint
the thing out and then you'd tip an old
Hoover yeah and there are other little
tricks you see if you've got a picture
that's been in the frame for around say
years you would have a clean Edge where
the frame is protected from the elements
right yes so what you used to do you'd
get ordinary Terps when the picture was
started to be aged you'd run your finger
about half an inch all the way around so
when they take it out yeah that's been
in the frame for a few years 100 years
that's what I used to do it then we used
to go in the auction room I'd be at one
side send me the other and ago and we
had a sign I was all suited and booted
but you had to be careful that the guy
that you get you saw in in the beginning
is not in the auction room so he'd be at
the back Sammy would be other side and
they go we're painting by Albert Derby
let's start the beating at 1500 pounds
we kept out of that when it gets to two
and a half thousand I'd Row in with a
bid you know 500 whatever and you do the
same but when did we got to about five
grand we think rights don't don't think
we should buy the blood you think about
yourself
I know Sammy would I would do this with
my tie always I'd go like that I'm out
and he would bro you take his cap off
his chilled me off that we're out I mean
just wait there's always to do it
amazing and it must have been
such a buzz it must have been like
seeing how far you could push it up
before bowing out I'm gonna tell you the
galleries I've hit even in your first
city of London but I can tell you in one
in Bond Street I it one huge gallery for
for about 50 grand 50 Grand and was this
was this back when you were younger
still yeah I was 19 years old so that
money bearing in mind how much you were
being paid to scrape rake the elephants
out
um that money that like 50 Grand must
have been a fortune back then oh it was
yeah so selling a painting for even two
thousand or three thousand pounds
um
was there a risk like what would have
happened if the auctioneer would have
looked at it and said no this is a fake
would you just have said okay fair
enough and left or would they accused
you or then you're right because in
those days if you were very confident
you'd be convincing but they didn't have
the technology you couldn't do it today
the technology they didn't bother you
know if he could see in his eyes out
that and it was pretty good aging under
glass as well very difficult you know
and it looked the business I mean 18
well look when you go into an auction
room you're standing next to your
picture which is two weeks old right
people coming up with their brochure and
going Yes Albert Derby I like this I'm
gonna have a property you keep an eye on
him then because you're in the preview
you know you get a preview of the and
you think right got that one got that
one got that one got that one so you
knew you'd fooled a lot of the dealers
you know and then because that's what we
would do but we did it all over the
country I mean I've been to places where
when my pictures up in the gallery so
that's one of mine oh what you've just
walked in
even when I was in prison I was knocking
at a fake by Samuel Palmer my Sammy when
I got I got 18 months actually for doing
a fake so how can you talk us through
that how did you get caught and how did
you get founded uh well let me tell you
the first time I went in Nick was um
I thought I followed a hippie trail with
my guitar go down to Cornwall and I got
on the train I got stuck in Dorchester
and I thought five in the morning you
know no food and I thought right got out
there and I walked up and Dorchester
High Street and I saw this hotel it was
like a guest house sort and I walked up
there and I saw this chandelier I
thought I love that so I took the sandal
here and the hundred day clock and I put
it outside and I wheeled it down in a
buried down the bloody High Street so I
got it to the station some nosy Burger
thought we'll see it going on he called
the old room please and I came in he'd
said to me hello he said max isn't it I
said I've seen you on your case he said
though do you open it up I said what do
you normally carry around the chandelier
like that I said I'll trade it to this
corner have it mended for my grandson I
said how about this hundred day clock
yes I do need timepiece so anyone I'm
down there so he nicked me went up in
front of the daughters and Nick because
I wouldn't give my um a home address
because I didn't want my mum to know he
gave me bloody four months but when you
go into Nick your whole will change
especially if you're an artist or you
can draw I mean I was I was banged up
first with um a three cell but I've got
my own cell you know Sammy came to see
me but it was good so all the boys say
hey Max you know because you know if
you're in it irrespective of what who
you are what you do if you're doing
funny things you know you know what I
mean your your life's hail I promise you
but because I was drawing I used to get
a half ounce of tobacco for doing a
doggy picture a girlfriend or something
like that they want a lot of chocolate
stuff right I said it's got bikini I
said no you've got a good imagination
that but it was a great feeling of
friendship in Nick yeah
all right it's Connor here one of The
Producers on extraordinary lives at LAD
Bible which is going to take a short
break from the show to talk about our
sponsor nordvpn now I'm a really big fan
of nordvpn and I use it loads when I
travel as much as I love getting some
sun I also want to keep up with my
favorite shows from back home and
nordvpn lets you do that and it's so
quick and easy to use to give you an
idea recently I was in Colombia and I
was able to watch the finale of
succession whilst relaxing by the pool
pure Bliss and because of nordvpn's
threat protection I was able to do this
using my hotel's free public Wi-Fi with
absolute Peace of Mind extraordinary
lives listeners can get an exclusive
nordvpn deal with a huge discount by
going to nordvpn.com forward slash
minutes and it's risk-free with Nora's
30-day money-back guarantee you'll also
get an additional bonus month by going
through nordvpn.com forward slash
minutes and this amazing deal is
included on all plans standard plus and
complete again you can get it now by
going to nordvpn.com forward slash
minutes that's nordvpn.com forward slash
minutes and so that first one was four
months yeah four months for for Nick in
the chandelier Furniture here in the
club in the club and you were still
young then right clock didn't work
anyway okay
but then but then so you came back out
and you went back went into the forgery
yeah and and how did they how did they
find out how did you get arrested for
forgery uh the first one I did was um I
did a Samuel I did a two Samuel Palmer
drawings
and uh I I there was a dealer called um
Otto he's gone now but I gave him two
Samuel Palmers to to sell in one in
London one in Manchester he'd been boat
in London and he got he got he got
blogged on it so and not only that he he
laid me in and he sold my magazine this
year he did it he's in cricket so I'm
there in at night at night I've got two
on the bloody easel so the door scams
and caves it in and then he comes stuck
and went all right randrick come on what
we said what's this what's on here I
don't know I've never seen him before so
it said and he said and he's yours said
no I said no no I I don't know where
they come from so anyway down the
station and uh you know fordry the
gallery charged me and I got I got I got
to 12 months in there okay it's quite a
long time for a young guy yeah but they
knew what I was doing they knew I'd done
a lot more well don't eat me before and
were you rich at that point in time no
so where was the money say you were
selling these forgeries
you know with semi we used to go through
it like there's no tomorrow you know we
were spending you know we used to buy
canvases and we live in the High Life in
London you know but uh you know it was
sort of an 11 Grand to 12 Grand you know
they we used to just go through it and
spend it you know but so yeah anyway
and so with Sammy Sammy was like a
manager in a way he was like my father
he said God bless him he he was he
looked a bit he looked very he was
Jewish but he looked very slick he had
his lovely coat on velvet collar or dead
nice nice suit nice tie anything but he
had the old Silk anger cheese you know
and uh but he was so good at the you
know getting into Providence that goes
with it and he and he was he was so
convincing you know species with two
ignorant people but he would there were
two different ways when he was selling
into a gallery like I'm not going to or
nearly mention the bloody carrier ripped
offering good yeah nearly slipped out
then of male gallery
[Laughter]
okay
so anyway but uh he he was too he was a
great actor he would go in and say no
when we sold the Samia Palmer so you
were going and so we've got this
painting that was left in Me by
so-and-so and so and so but on the other
day when we went the auction rooms we
would shoot we were starting to Jekyll
and hide you know hello John got
smudging of course anyway that's it
that's how it used to be that's the
forgery side and what did you do were
you involved in any other sort of cons
or was it just the other oh yeah uh do
you want to know the ceramic duck
mystery then I'd I'd love to hear this
around two three years ago I was no
money at all living in my little flat
you know I live above a chemist and I've
got my decoration been up for 11 years
never take them down Christmas
decorations yeah okay 11 years all it's
all guitars and old telephones and
radios and it and I've got no money and
I saw this advert and said paint your
own duck saw Ducks so you send away to
this Belgium company and they send you a
a ceramic that set of three all glazed
White sold for hello I painted them that
look like basic Ducks right you know a
little bit of engine on it and I thought
they cost me 12 quid put them into eBay
they went from 190 the first night so I
threw it right I'm having this so I
ordered another 12 boxes
hello Mr branded yes sir he went uh
rather a lot of ducks coming our way all
right so what's that all about then so I
said we believe they're fake I mean oh
are they so I didn't know that he said
we're gonna have to ban you I said uh is
that for life so you said yes I said
I'll sell them out for a duck then you
went she suck could nailed that one he
said you're now a band for life I said
sir question please any chance of
remission Knuckles to get in Nick you
went not at all banned for life eBay now
wow so that was eBay officially calling
you and saying I've got one in the bag
so I was going to show you have you
really you've been you banned for faking
a ceramic down ceramic Ducks wow so so
yeah no remission okay okay
um
that story is from me I haven't been
expected to come out let's see where
were we so we were back so you were
working just going back through your
life
um let's go back to your most famous
forgeries like did you you said that you
didn't do sort of like the big names
like picassos and stuff but what are
some of the the more famous pieces faked
well
um well it's the lesser-known Marine
artist of that year that probably I mean
you know I know you don't know them but
you know you get Jonathan Crone uh
Albert Derby uh Clarkson Stanfield these
would make five to six seven thousand so
I found a niche in the market you know
it for there are some forges that today
that there's a German guy is very good
then Megan is very good but you can't
get away with it so we hit a market
whereas they just didn't know damn I
don't know how many thousands don't
forget we were doing four a month for 12
years so there's that a lot of them out
there you probably haven't been on your
wall
so do you think that's possible that
people have that your paintings
absolutely of course they are yeah wow
and probably being they're being handed
down from like yeah it's a heirloom
sorry I'm so sorry for that yeah I'm
Gonna Leave You this in my world yeah
right no no no
I I do feel sometimes no I don't feel
guilty come on man that's a
lieuty okay so um how how long did your
partnership with sunny last for
yeah oh I think the last time I saw him
is um I saw him when I met the craze
I'll tell you that story yeah yeah uh
Sammy went down to West country oh
somebody got Nick that's right you got
from bessemen it's something he got he
got 12 months so and so he was into all
sorts of different oh absolutely well
yeah and at this point did it feel like
like at that point in time were you
trying to become rich or were you just
trying to find a way I love the buzz of
it I didn't I still don't care today I
do you know if okay people now got a
large following I mean I I paint you
know I do I love doing care of edgios I
I think my secret is that I could copy
anybody's style you know that was it you
know but so I'm happy in my little where
I am you know so was part of the buzz
the fact that somebody thought your work
they would mistake it for the original
it was the fact that you could copy this
well if you if you take a if you take a
um if you take a like um oh god listen
and Matt Turner right we used to take a
toner painting and it had make a sea
picture like you know
um shipping off Dover or something and
we'd I'd turn it around and put that
boat over there that wolf over there so
it's his style that my painting and his
because I could copy his style you know
lovely Seas you know with a like the boy
in the water and that sort of thing and
the Wolf you know I did a lot of them
yeah but so yeah and did you did you
love the paintings oh are you doing it
as a means to an end no I loved painting
yeah I loved the buzz and I'm going to
say it I quite loved the buzz in the
auctions as well right and it was it was
a great turn on honestly you know I
think oh wow I'm not saying auctioneers
are very nice but you know it was it was
exciting you know out there and you
think God just got eight grand on that
burger okay and so let's move on to yeah
because you did have a sort of run-in
with the well you had an encounter with
the Kray twins didn't yeah well
I was busking there and my two songs
long and dusty road and this spy came up
from there go hello John do you do
smudges like from photographs I went yes
I think so he said if I'll be back in a
minute and he went up the road came back
with a picture of a lady of about 50 or
whatever and uh he said can you do that
I said yeah on the 24 20 or whatever it
might be I said you know about ready for
next week mate I said yep so I came back
next week with it it's a nice frame it
and it was uh it was his mother it was
the Cruise's mother and a violet so I
did it and they said my friends are up
the road so I go up the road there I'm
walking behind him it's a sunny day I
walked into the pub called the Ola
Lonsdale and it was very bright outside
so I couldn't focus properly and I
thought I got in there as soon as my
eyes adjusted I thought oh my God that's
that's that's that's
um Rodney Christ into the table and
there's Reggie at the bar and Frankie
Fraser's in the corner Ronnie comes up
to me and said hello son he said hello
so don't call me sir don't call me sir
he said uh my boy said you'd done the
smudge then went yes Mr cray he said
right let's have a look then he took the
painting out and it went all bloody
quiet oh my God you didn't like it and
he went just crying he looked at me and
he went Reggie have a look at this
Reggie overlooked his bloody brilliant
mate I can't believe look at it it's got
mum he's got the eyes right in here did
you do do this son I went yes not trying
not to say sir and he said sit down I
sat with a cray there and a crater in
the bloody middle and they had big
shoulders those buggers that was only
tiny and he went I love it absolutely
love it I must show you and I was going
well I said give him a one I said I
thought one quid it was a hundred pounds
and 68 it's like giving you um like
giving you a thousand wow and then this
is the crunch game and he went yeah he
said I love it and he went and he put
his hand on when he went and he's a good
looking kid as well in he looks like a
pop star then he said to me going out he
went Maxi come here he said and he put
his arm around my show did you must kind
of have achieve with my mom in Balance
Road I said I can't Mister I've got to
go to church on Sunday so I'm out of
that one
foreign
so at that point in time with where you
lived in London with a craze like did
you know who they were immediately
yeah yeah but that wasn't their manner I
mean that was unusual for them to be
there but the boyfriend was Chrissy
Chrissy with a boyfriend you know but so
Ronnie was Ronnie was different I mean
he was different but yeah anyway that
was so so well it's lucky they liked it
I guess isn't it yeah well I'd have been
under concrete if I hadn't had yes I
said stop no I don't want you know
Charlie did you know no Charlie cray
Charlie was the other is that the older
brother yeah he was all right Charlie he
wasn't like but Ronnie was not right but
Reggie was okay Rich actually I met
Francesca this girl when he married you
know only fleetingly in a coffee bar
when I was with him yeah yeah and what
what about
um did you ever come you know
what you're talking about with the kind
of like the the little scams in the
auction house with Sammy and that kind
of thing it all sounds quite almost fun
like adventurous but obviously the The
Craze are a darker side of crime and
more threatening did you ever brush up
against any other oh yeah intimidating
areas no no I meant no no no intimidate
done after that because well not with
the craze I mean did you ever experience
were there ever people who tried to
extort you or make you do art for them
or anything oh yeah lots of times yeah
but you know like you know try to do a
number on me you know say do this and
know and want it for my house and then
they they take it down the auction rooms
I'm very wise to that you know but no
it's it's been a it's been a um it's a
good old it's mine is a roller coaster
you know there's no way I'm going to be
a pop star and you know you're too
bloody songs you know or or when I was
in goldings you know when I walked down
Bent Tree Lane and when Pinhead said to
me will Maxes said what do you want to
do when you leave you said you've got a
choice I said you could be boot making
gardening or Woodworkers it should be a
cobbler for Christ's sake but he says
what do you want to do I said I want to
be an out to him not possible
uh do you know what bernardo's was
pretty cruel it'd be very cruel you know
and was was there never any point that
you tried to just become an artist in
your own life I tried so hard I tried
you just so people like um David Hurst
and Tracey Emin and and hockney there
you get that break you know they get
that lucky break but I I didn't care I
didn't care I knew I was good I mean you
know but I'm a self-taught painter you
know I'm you know I'm sort of good at
what I do but I'm happy in what I'm
doing now I do I do good care of agile
you'll see that on the book have you got
a copy of them yes yes we do you look at
that all those pictures are mine you
know and what was the during that period
of the forgery what was the most money
you ever made from a painting
about 80 grand 80 and how old were you
at that point 24.
so that was a forgery that people
thought was a real painting it was a
Dutch winter scene okay and it was right
the canvas was right the frame was right
I paid 250 for the frame and I sold it I
can't tell you where it went but it did
lots Road sorry
but so when you say that you can't say
do you think there's there's the the no
these paintings are still in circulation
I will if they have become will they
tell you yeah I'm going to confess to
another crime okay well okay we'll we'll
cut it out if we feel like it's very
difficulties it's amusing right now I do
a lot for Charities you probably know
bernardo's right I made a lot of money
I.T 90 grand you know and I give a
painting every year now I do a limited
edition horse prints right and um
I was at a charity and this lady said to
me you do so much for but the variety
Club why don't you do something for my
children at the cellular hospice and I
went up to see it and I was you know you
know so upset and I said yeah I can do
it so I had a Leicester Pickett was
riding a horse called chinoso and I
published it to 100 no 250 prints so I
said I went to Leicester Pickett's agent
I said can I have him to endorse it and
he went yes Seven Grand I went commands
for charity so I went back to my studio
and I faked off 100 signage okay that's
just all right and then unfortunately
Susan Pickett was happened to be in Kent
and one of my prints came up for auction
in a charity to at a garden fate that's
not my ham signature so I banged the
rights picked up on the same afternoon
same next morning you know and I got
with all the face they took me in BC
said I don't know Nick you Max I really
don't you did it for charity I went no
no you got to do it so you said right
we're going to bail you now so so you
can take those prints we don't need them
as evidence we've got enough so as I'm
going out the custard office said hey
Max can I buy one I said do you want
less to pick it or just just me anyway I
just have you
[Applause]
[Music]
so um yeah I mean it must have been good
if he was willing to buy it on your way
of the police station and what what
happened next is in like you know what
was the next stage of your life after
the um how long did the art forgery go
on for 15 years 15 years okay so what
point did you decide to stop doing it
and what no I didn't I didn't stop I was
forced to stop okay well tell us about
that well you know I I found my Niche
you know not certainly not Mickey child
playing that never can happen but I
found I've got instant habit of people
knowing who I am and was faking but I
didn't seem to get the prizes like in
auction because the antique trade was
going down the pen you know especially
in Brighton there aren't many antique
dealers left you know I had a few
dealers down there and I thought I just
sort of traveled along very happy you
know okay you know my only crime name
was the ceramic Ducks but I could get
over it I'm not hardly going to get
licensed for that am I so and then all
sorts of things but then then suddenly I
thought I I still want to paint you know
I still want to paint my caravaggios my
banksies which they're all going to have
one on their kitchen door before I I
leave them in this place ain't nobody
right yeah
trying to get my number to see if I
could do it for you is that true yeah
for people listening on the podcast the
sound manners unfortunately been trying
to uh commit art fraud with Max on the
previous record
yeah anyway yes so it's all good so you
kept
doing it for 15 years in the art of
forgery how much money do you think that
you made in total if you had to take a
guess from us oh dear oh my God I think
about
could be 100 million just a million
million wow well you've got to run what
they were going for afterwards yeah you
know when I say I reckon I've made I did
about about 600 000 but you didn't look
at it like that you just saw
these pictures are everywhere I mean if
you think uh 15 years
when I was with Sammy with semi for
eight years we turned out four a month
yeah I mean look I'll give you an
example where did you say did we ever
get caught I nearly did I was um we went
to Arundel you know lots of antiques up
there so Sammy were with me and he had I
said listen you go into that antique
shop I'll go into this one I said don't
forget check it out and it was about
half about 200 yards away from me
another antique shop so I'm doing
selling I'm selling a Henderson coaching
scene and I've got and I've got 800 quid
in my hand right Sammy comes running
went Max get out of it quick get out he
said they've sussed him because the
bloody Guy picked up the picture and it
was still wet so so this two big
anteaters and they were bloody big
or whatever and yeah we shot out there
down there into a High Street we
couldn't find a car couldn't find it
where's the Canadian car I don't know so
we hid in the bushes for two and a half
hours just we could see them going up
and down they were the little things
used to happen you know and was that was
art forgeries like a thing back then
with the other people doing it oh we no
there aren't many doing it no weren't
many right no I mean uh you know if
there weren't many no so in terms of the
auctioneers it's not like they would
have been looking out for forgeries no
that's that today that who who is an Art
Forger today the German guy belter at
shotting oh no no no but no it's I mean
you couldn't walk well you've tried to
walk around with a Picasso and say this
you can't do it that's why the Lesser
known that's why we made a lot of money
because I'm going to say it the artists
that I know couldn't do what I could do
because I could rip I could reproduce
the colors of that day I'm very good at
Seas you know making the seeds from the
18th century late 18th century you know
you know but they're collectibles you
know especially sort of people like
Albert Derby and Jonathan Chrome we did
a load of those but there are a lot of
them and you know the story of when I
was faking in Nick don't you no tell us
that one well I was in Dorchester and
Nick I've been twice in Dorchester and
Sammy said what were you in for I was
forgery okay right okay so Sammy came to
see me and it was on a Friday visiting
day and he went hello son keeping your
head down means dude's time right I went
yeah I'm all right Sam all right said uh
do you fancy doing any work I said what
do you want to do a fake and send it out
by post get the screws to deliver it I
said what are you talking about he went
no sit up my sleeve I've got six rolls
of old newspaper old paper that I Nick
from the library used to go in the
library with a razor blade Nick out the
pages from somebody very expensive books
you know shame I know that roll it up
put it up his sleeve why because that
was the right age because of the old
paper yeah okay the paper was 1830s and
that's that's the period or 17 something
which is the period of Samuel Palmer you
know so years ago there and I wasn't
high risk you see so I had no problem
there and he would be uh go right so I
know you're doing that don't forget
we're Father and Son I'd say hello Dad
definitely all the time don't say hello
Sammy and there you go away you're all
right I said how are you finding it I
went yeah I'm keeping my head down you
know sold a few got a bit of tobacco
ain't good he went listen he said right
put you because I used to wear a jacket
they had the university the Beady jacket
he had a big Overcoat on it's bloody
middle of the summer but didn't care so
out would come in slits of paper he'd be
holding my hand like my son like my dad
and he'd slide it out there and they go
up my sleeve right and go right and the
screws didn't bother me I mean they like
me anyway you know they didn't look good
they looked from the top the deck you
know looking down there's nothing going
on and uh then I think right up my
sleeve right I've got them in right got
how many you got there five okay that's
it back to myself sir you're recording
so what boys go to the cell slap him in
my Bible think right pen and ink pen ink
no problem Samuel Palmer ink drawing
because I was quite good at getting a
reference book from the library just
copied them and change them around and
do the same thing one day I had a sale
search which is very usual and this the
the um the governor came in and Ally
Maxi said they're doing all right now he
said you're a good lad he said when you
out said uh I know I've got another
month so he went right and he picks up
the bloody Bible with two same
Apartments
he went yep go buy the good book here
Max the I'm keeping it down soon
that's the way I'm going when I'm out I
should follow them
well good lad good lad well done Max you
said you're still painting he said oh
that's nice oh well you've got two for
nothing anyway you've got two other
paintings and that was it since Sammy
would would come again and I'll do the
same thing by giving him back the
pictures by the little Lego good lead
then you go back frame them up put them
in auction so you were spending the time
that you were imprisoned for art fraud
doing more art fraud wow and I then I'd
about four or five grand when I came out
right so and if look if they said these
are branded how could I mean Nick
and what was the longest you were ever
in prison for 18 months 18 months for
the same for art forgery yeah yeah
you've got to remember Ben in the days
of um uh 68 when I was in Nick it was so
different I mean you had exercise yard
you know
um you'd go on the outer ring the
weirdos would go to Inner ring reverse
to us and you had slop out I mean you
had a pop a potty now they've got all
TVs in place they patient you know it's
all slop out it was a was a PO and you
had to have a crap in there as well I
was falling off the bloody thing I
couldn't balance myself on it so you had
to take that in the morning they go slop
out and the screws have run down to do
rinse and rinse it and back yourself
then breakfast and then you'd better do
a bit of work I was breaking up I was
making fenders for the um for the uh
fishing boats up in Hull wow yeah and so
what when you got out from that like
what what did you do for the rest of
your life you know did you ever go
straight did you ever have just a normal
nine-to-five job forget withdrawal
symptoms
from from you know the judge that what
you get withdrawal systems you said why
Mr Brandon you persist on doing this
it's like this so that's uh so you're
you're honor whatever I'll see when I
was seeing all cameras I just got a
paint on it I kind of I may have been
counseling for it but it doesn't work so
that's how it used to be and but what
was it that made you want to do I just
love the buzz on the sleeping yeah so
you just weren't interested in just
painting for yourself it had to I knew I
couldn't get anywhere with it yeah so a
forger I must be I'm a Craftsman that
lost his lost his way that's how I feel
it and you and you did that so did you
do that for your whole life yeah well oh
I worked in a Holiday Camp
uh what else about hot circus Holiday
Camp yeah I've done sort of many things
but uh always been art it's been all
those years you know still doing it now
and I love it I you know I live above a
chemist uh I get Viagra I just tap on
the ceiling and my chemist brings it up
in a basket you can edit that out
and do you still paint regularly yeah
well I've got a Banksy on I've got a
Banksy nearly finished
called The Joker which I know you love
no they're all coming in from every
bloody Direction this guy wants to
promote me have you heard another forger
called John Mayer I haven't no well he
he's on the books he's on his books you
know and he's going the same way he take
they sell art but yet you don't own it
will you you own it but you don't own
the picture okay I think it's called NFC
yes nft nf2 yes what is that what is it
what's that interview it means
non-fungible token but it's basically
what you've just described that you own
so they get a token instead of my
picture no they get your picture but
it's digital oh it's not the actual
painting he said when he left me he went
on Tick Tock he said I've just left Max
brand it believe me I've got to do this
this is something else this guy and I
thought yeah I trust him as well and he
said we're going to draw the contracts
up yeah well I I I'm I'll make sure that
it's dead right on there you know but I
want my this is this is what I love lad
Bible because you can tell who you
really are you know and when you at the
beginning you told us about being banned
from eBay how long ago did that happen
oh three years ago three years ago so
quite recently so you know obviously I
don't want you to get in trouble but it
feels like you've still got it in you to
do a little bit
a little bit of the let me have a chance
on you
I'm too old for Nick now yeah yeah and
you and and you said earlier that it's
harder these days with the oh absolutely
technology and the ways of yeah yeah you
know they've got oh they can tell you
what day you painted it where and all
that in my day they didn't bother as
long as it looked the business you know
and you know are you to stand there next
to a fake that's supposed to be 17 15.
it's only two and a half weeks old great
Buzz showing you once better than the
new woman how do I read it well when you
look back at your life which is it's
been like you say from the from the sort
of upbringing in bernardos to working
with the elephants to the art forgery
you know it's been quite varied and
roller coaster you know what's something
that you think you've learned from it
what's it taught you uh
what have I learned I think I've learned
to I'm more well I've always loved
people I've learned that you know you're
on the last train to San Fernando you've
got to be bloody happy and I'm going to
go out with a big old bang I don't give
a monkeys about money but I do I I do
miss that old um that old buzz you know
and and I'm I missed the 60s and 68s and
you know when it was a lot of styling
you know and I love art deco I love the
40s you know I've got watch now this is
a 1940s but it's people I love now so
the so the thing that you find
interesting now in your life as people
and interactions oh absolutely yeah even
the text Drive you've got my life story
we pass at the time didn't it no he went
I said no part two next week
it's great you know because you can use
lead by which is a stepping stone but
it's lovely sometimes when you're out I
was out in the pub the other night in
nip Ryan station and he walks in and he
comes and shook my hand straight away he
said you're a legend I said oh come on
so that's a bit strong I said probably I
am yeah you're right well this is just
someone who'd recognize you from a video
because it's that Bible oh I see you
look at some of the comments on that
Bible your Governor ought to pick up on
that you know Netflix he said why isn't
he not making a movie out of this guy
you know I'll get the final question I
wanted to ask you is do you have any
regrets
uh
uh do you know I don't know what Ben
don't actually have ever great
no I I know I don't um yeah I wish I
hadn't have um been always I wish I'd
have been there more for my mother
because I was always missing or in Nick
you know I mean there are uh yeah
because I I'm now sort of uh my daughter
is happy now my granddaughter is lovely
and I'm I'm good now I'm at a good place
now but you know I will say I still
think that bike was the best though I
really do I don't care if you're not
allowed to plug it but I am well we
definitely will put that in the editor
so thanks very much look Max it's been
um fascinating to hear your story it's
been brilliant to have you here thank
you so much for your time all right God
bless you all tell me my leg fell over
and then as I've tried to get up he shot
me again he went through my willy shot
my willy ah done my well down my willy
as well went into my willy down my willy
and shot my white testicle into my pants
and then I've tried